We have just finished looking at the skeletal mesh components and will now move on to the
groom components and dive into the groom asset editor.
Then we will look at the LOD sync and metahuman component.
Now let's jump back into Unreal Engine and begin exploring the groom components.
Back inside of Unreal Engine, I have opened up the blueprint for Lena CQ from the metahuman
introduction course.
I will use this blueprint as I go through the groom components.
The groom components are children of the face component as they follow the head.
The components include the eyelashes, peach fuzz, the eyebrows, the hair, the mustache
and the beard.
When looking at the groom components, we will see that even though this metahuman does not
have a mustache or beard, those groom components will serve as placeholders for those assets.
When we select the hair component in the details panel, each groom asset comes with its own
material instance and depending on the style, it will have one for the hair, the helmet
and carts.
If we open this material instance, there will be a number of parameters you can adjust
to control the appearance of the hair without ever having to open the master material.
Now if we go back to the metahuman blueprint, right below the materials, we will have a
groom asset and groom binding asset.
The binding asset is used to attach and skin a groom component to a skeletal mesh.
If importing your own custom groom, ensure you assign the skeletal mesh that this groom
should be bound to in the groom binding asset.
Let's open up this groom asset and dock it here.
With the groom asset editor, we can manage aspects of our groom, such as how the groom
is rendered, how it handles physics simulation and manages LODs.
Starting with the LOD panel, this is where we can control the switch between LODs based
on screen size in the viewport and specify what type of geometry it should switch to.
For example, for this groom, LOD0 uses strands and LOD1 uses strands.
For LOD2 and 3, it uses cards.
Next, we have the interpolation panel.
Interpolation defines how groom curves should move with respect to skinning and physics
simulation.
For large skeletal mesh deformations and simulation, when RBF interpolation is enabled, it will
help to preserve the original groom's position, regardless of the physics simulation and deformation.
Next, we have the strands panel.
This controls the rendering properties related to the strand geometry.
It can be used to control physical properties of the hair, such as the hair tip scale, for
example, which can make the hair look finer if the value is set to a lower number.
Next, we have the cards panel.
This is where you can set up the card geometry and specify if you want the engine to generate
cards procedurally or if you want to import your own cards.
The Meshes panel manages the mesh geometry that is used for LODs.
When LODs switch for the grooms, they go from strands to cards to meshes.
And this is where you can manage those assets.
The Materials panel is where you define what materials are used by the groom asset.
The Physics panel is where you can enable or disable physics simulation and control
the simulation properties, such as the external forces, the bend, stretch, and collision constraint,
and strand parameters.
Now before we move on, let's do a quick review of what we just covered.
If we open up a groom asset, we can use the groom asset editor to adjust a variety of
properties.
The LOD panel is where we can control and configure what the groom switches to for each
LOD by setting the visibility, screen size, and geometry types that are used.
For example, strand based grooms may perform poorly when using multiple metahumans at the
highest LOD setting.
By changing the geometry to use cards or meshes, this will boost performance.
If you want to force card based geometry for all hair grooms instead of strands when working
in a level, you can use the console variable shown on the bottom right.
The interpolation panel is used to control how a groom's curves should move with respect
to the skinned meshes and physics simulation when a groom is bound to a skeletal mesh and
skinning is used for deformation.
During deformation and physics simulation, RBF interpolation is what preserves the original
groom shape.
By disabling this, the groom will use the local skin rigid transform it is bound to.
And disabling this may come in handy if for instance, the eyebrows on your metahuman
begin to flutter even when there is no animation applied.
The strands panel is where we can control the rendering properties related to the strand
geometry of a groom.
Some of those properties include the hair width, root scale, and hair tip scale.
The hair shadow density reduces or increases the amount of shadow on the groom as we can
see on the images on the right.
We can decrease the amount to help with flickering hair shadows and transmission.
The cards panel is where you can set up your card geometry and textures and specify if
you want the engine to procedurally generate them or to import your own.
The meshes panel is where you can set the mesh, textures, and mapping to specific hair
grooms and LODs.
And the materials panel is where you can define what materials are used by a specific groom
asset.
And finally, the physics panel is where you can enable or disable physics simulation and
the simulation properties of things such as the external forces, collision, and strand
parameters.
Keep in mind that some groom assets will have more than one solver setting, so if you wish
to disable simulation for a groom asset, you may want to scroll down and check that you
have disabled it in the additional solver settings.
Now that we have a better understanding of the groom component and have also looked at
the groom asset editor, let's jump back into Unreal Engine and now take a look at the
LOD sync component.